okay today I'm going to talk to you
about stopping distances so stopping
distances can be shown with this simple
equation that I'm going to show you
right now so the stopping distance
equals the thinking distance and we'll
talk about what that is in just a second
plus the braking distance so we can
always find out the stopping distance by
adding these things together now it's
really important that we now know what
that means so we're going to look at a
particular example so let's imagine I
have this little van right here okay so
this van here is traveling along a road
it's driving along the road and all of a
sudden out of nowhere a little kid
blunders into the road they walk into
the road now obviously this car is going
to try and slam its brakes on as quickly
as possible otherwise it's gonna hit
this child so first of all we need to
think about the thinking distance
because that is the distance that the
car travels while the person reacts in
order to touch the brake so that's the
brake right there
apologies for my bad drawings but this
is the person sat in the seat of their
car okay
so what they do is they've seen first of
all they see the kid then they have to
react so obviously bit surprise they
have to react and putting their foot
down on the brake while they're reacting
that takes time it takes time for them
to react and put their foot on the brake
during that time the car is still moving
so that's why it's called the thinking
distance this is the distance the car
travels while the person reacts to what
they've seen so let's think first of all
what can affect the thinking distance so
the thinking distance first
of all is affected by speed now this
doesn't mean if you're traveling slower
you're going to react faster or vice
versa what it means is if you're going
faster even if you react to the same
rate the same speed reaction time if
you're traveling fast you would have
traveled further than if you were
traveling if you were going at a slow
speed so it might take you let's say
half a second to react if you're
traveling really fast you'd have
traveled further in that half second
than if you're traveling really slow now
the other things that can affect your
thinking distance is your reaction time
so how quickly you are reacting to
things and there's lots of different
things that can affect reaction time
including tiredness so if you're really
really tired it's gonna massively affect
your reaction time also alcohol this is
one of the many reasons why it's not
advised
well why it's illegal to drink and drive
because if you're drunk
your reaction time is slower so
therefore you're thinking distance be
greater you'll have gone further before
you manage to apply the brakes also
different drugs can affect your thinking
time
I'm sorry thinking distance even and
finally distractions so if there's
something going on in the car that
you're not meaning you can't pay full
attention to the road it means you will
travel further before you react to put
your foot on the brake so that's what
thinking distance means the distance
traveled before you react so then you
slam your foot on the brake now this car
is then going to come to a halt now
breaking distance the second you apply
the brakes it doesn't stop straightaway
cars will apply the brakes then they'll
be increased friction and the car will
come to a halt but that can be quite a
long distance so braking distance it's
just the distance that you travel from
the second you apply the brakes
the second you stop so here I've reacted
this place has reacted foots go down the
brakes and he's come to a stop luckily
in this example it's just before the kid
so different things that could affect
breaking this that's first of all your
speed if you're going faster you'll have
a bigger braking distance the state of
your brakes are they worn down or are
they okay the mass of the vehicle if
your vehicle has a greater mass it's
going to have a greater braking distance
and also the road surface that's a big
one
so things about the road surface means
is it I see is it wet both of these two
things will reduce the friction with the
road between the tires and the road so
the braking distance will go further now
this whole distance together the Finke
distance and the braking distance
combined that gives us our stopping
distance the stopping distance is the
thinking distance added to the braking
distance now this is why we have speed
limits because if we have a quick look
at this we can see that speed affects
both thinking distance and braking
distance so the faster we go the greater
the stopping distance the more likely we
are to have an accident
so if I quickly show you this figure
what we can see here is it shows the
typical stopping distances at different
speeds so if you're going at 20 miles an
hour then it's only 12 meters stopping
distance that means 6 meters you travel
before you hit the brakes then 6 meets
the stop that's only 12 meters whereas
if you're going 70 miles an hour
a typical braking distance is 96 meters
that's an enormous distance that you can
travel before you come to a halt so just
to summarize stopping distances include
Finke distance a braking distance thank
you this is all about how fast you can
react and how far your travel how far
your vehicle travels while you react and
your braking distance is once you've
applied the brakes how far do you travel
thank you